John.
Well, Karim Khan was keen to tell us
that this is really
just the first step in
what promises to be a long journey.
The arrest warrants
that were given out today
for President Putin and also for the
Russian high
commissioner for children,
Maria Liv over Bill Oliver.
These are just the first to essentially
there may be more coming.
There may be other areas
that they will be exploring.
There is no shortage
of alleged war crimes
that have taken place in Ukraine.
The prosecutor's office
here from the ICC
have made multiple trips to Ukraine,
but they were keen really to stress
the importance of this historic day.
Take a look.
There are many different war crimes
or potential war crimes
that we've seen playing out in Ukraine,
whether it's the bombing of the theater
in Mariupol,
where people were sheltering,
civilians were sheltering,
whether it's the atrocities of Butcher.
Why did you decide to pursue this line
of prosecution first?
We are absolutely right.
Firstly, I stated when I was outside St
Andrew's Church
in Russia about a year ago,
just less than a year ago,
that Ukraine is a crime scene
and there's many terrible allegations
that have been received,
and we're analyzing them
and reviewing them.
But before my election as prosecutor,
before I started in June of 2021,
I also identified
the crimes against all crimes
affecting children
are under investigated
and under-reported.
And this is why when you look at the
the factual matrix,
the actual evidence that we received,
it was only right and appropriate
to focus on the most vulnerable
parts of our society, which are children.
We understand that
over Belova is the Russian Commissioner
for children.
She's been very vocal and visible
in her role.
How did you take the next step also
in terms of pushing for the prosecution
of President Putin himself?
And how unusual is that?
Well, I've said
repeatedly over the last year
that we don't start with targets,
that we start with the evidence.
We investigate
incriminating and
exonerating evidence equally.
We want to find the truth.
We are statutorily required
to get to the truth.
And we, as I said,
started looking at a range of ways,
spectrum of allegations.
But the evidence was quite clear
because what has been said publicly
from those individuals,
what has become available
from publicly available sources, and also
the result of our direct investigations
ourselves, cooperation with other states
and also Ukraine,
that this
these crimes appear
to have been committed.
And one follows the evidence.
And the simple reality is
these crimes have not been hidden.
It's the first time in history
any head of state
of the permanent members
of the five permanent members
of the Security Council
has had a warrant of arrest
issued by independent
and impartial judges.
It shouldn't give us any celebration.
It's a matter of real regret
that we've had to do this.
The evidence compelled us to move
in this manner.
It's a historic moment, certainly.
But will we ever see
President Putin in the dock?
Well, the president of the court
made it very clear
our job is to independently
and impartially,
without any political motivations
or agendas.
Look at apply the law to the facts,
the facts that have been verified,
that have been
independently collected
and rigorously analyzed.
Now it's for others to decide
whether or not
arrest opportunities are available
and if so, to enforce them.
The first is many thought
it was impossible
that powerful leaders like
former President
Milosevic,
former President Charles Taylor,
Karadzic, Mladic and John,
commander of Rwanda,
accused the pan of Cambodia.
The list goes on.
He said Habré
would ever be subjected
to the rule of law,
and yet they were
some of them are in custody.
And, of course, award is back with us.
Clarissa.
No expectation, obviously,
that Vladimir Putin
would surrender or be arrested.
So did the ICC give you a sense
of how it intends to proceed legally?
Well,
that's the question
really, John, because the ICC can't trial
can't have a trial
of someone in absentia.
But what they can do,
according to prosecutor Khan and again,
this hasn't
been done historically,
but there is legal precedent for it
is what they call a confirmation hearing
in absence.
And that would essentially allow
for the evidence to be preserved
in a judicial setting in a timely way,
paving the way
for some potential future trial.
What they have seen.
Traditionally the ICC is that
very rarely do people
charged with war crimes
actually come to face justice
until those wars have reached an end.
And whichever side is
victorious gets to choose who ends up
facing trial at the ICC.
So what they want to do,
at least with this possibility
of the confirmation
hearing, is ensure
that that evidence
is put out there in a timely manner,
that victims of these alleged atrocities
are able
to still have their day in court,
even if it might be
quite some time before
you would potentially see
President Vladimir Putin
appearing on trial, though,
I think for the moment that does
seem like a very distant prospect, John.
Of course, to stay with us,
I want to bring in Matthew Chance
and Ivan Watson.
Ivan, what has the reaction
been from the Ukrainian government
to these arrest warrants?
John, the Ukrainian government
has been applauding
this decision,
the arrest warrant issued
by the International Criminal Court.
According to government statistics,
they say that
some 16,226 Ukrainian children,
the government believes, have been taken
and deported to Russia since the start
of the Russian invasion
a bit more than a year ago.
Take a listen
to what
the Ukrainian president, Volodymyr
Zelensky, had to say about this,
which he calls an historic decision
resulting in the U.S.
separating children from their families,
depriving them of any opportunity
to contact their relatives.
Hiding children in Russia.
Dispersing them to remote regions.
All this is obvious Russian state policy,
state decisions and state evil,
which begins
with the first official of the state.
So, you know, another top Ukrainian
official has just called this
a first step.
Meanwhile, the top prosecutor
in the country,
he says that he hopes
that this will make other world leaders
think twice about in the future,
shaking hands with Vladimir Putin
or sitting down at the negotiating
table with him
now that he's
effectively become a suspected
war criminal.
Well, the ICC move is important.
It's also important,
I think, to to understand
that the Ukrainian judicial system
that police here on the ground,
that investigators
and prosecutors,
that they are also separately actively
gathering evidence
for their own cases to accuse
Russian military commanders
and individual Russian soldiers
of alleged war crime so that after
every kind of rocket strike
or artillery strike
on a Ukrainian city or town,
after every death of a civilian.
You have police coming in later,
if it's at all
safe in an area,
gathering evidence
and putting their own cases together
to try to prosecute, prosecute.
Russian military units,
we're probably going
to see
more of this coming from
just the Ukrainian judicial system
in the months and years ahead.